ok gesetz
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft exit auf
dem hero server zusammen immer noch mit
lp mit kev hallo hallo und das lässt
mein flugzeug sehr gut gegangen ich muss
mich durch meinen eigenen eigens
gebauten turm graben stadt zurück ich
schmeiße eben konzerns sind scheiße
items ihr weg die enorme blöd da ja die
ganzen bogen und so aus der monster
falle
was sonst oft fehler da und ich konnte
auch spitzer kannst dann hat man auch
ganz einmal benutzen den stadtteil diana
das ein fehler
das sind sachen die ich noch brauche ich
muss immer noch xp fahren weil ich mir
ja endet kurz mit teilweiser übel sagt
gibt wenn sogar noch ein bisschen hast
du eigentlich noch bergauf deinem ändert
einen spot ob sich das lohnt habe ich
nicht dass irgendwo im wald oder ich
kann es aber nicht unter packen ja noch
weg ist ein echter dass die gegner
wegfliegen
das streikende dran bist ja deswegen das
ist nicht doof deswegen weiß ich auch
nicht
also ich würde nicht drauf tun gut feier
aspect machen eins drauf an breaking
mädels diamanten apples gegenteil auch
sie würde ich gerne essen alter ja okay
es sind ein paar zahlen drauf liebst du
mich das echt mal einfach einem abtasten
jetzt jemand mit rot-rot der mann schwer
verletzt aber das liegt direkt vor wird
ist echt gut gebaut was im livestream
gebaut
nee das habe ich nur an den folgen
geburt kommen auf youtube gesehen ach so
ich dachte jetzt im leitstelle gebaut
und damit den usern so als hilfe aber
auch gut ihre feuchte mir ausgedacht das
konzept diese rüstung du ich hab noch
ein armes land wo ich diamond helmut und
so was alles ab den kannst du dir mit
neben dem freundlich nimmt das einfach
mal mit in eine komische studium zurück
wenn du weißt dass ich auch fahren
wollte kommt zu mir den vorgarten hier
du stehst du gerade hier kurz alle sechs
schöne nachbarn bei der sonne so darabos
das ist futter das behalte ich habe noch
nie so eine liebhaber gefunden in dem
assange die person habe ich drei stück
diesen gollia
was bringen die wenn du die neben
pflanzen tust dann bist du schon drei
mal drei blog radius dann wachsen
schneller drumherum ehrlich ja nicht
ganz klar aber noch drei stück oder drei
stück habe ich ja die die kanzel
theoretisch einfach wenn feld haben so
auf die wasser spur linie ja was ist
denn geil was ich gut finde ist einen
kotten farm hier eigentlich so das ist
das was die nahe dass ich was das find
ich geil finde ich geil ist doch einfach
so gut dass ihn ein string machen ich
will jetzt nicht einfach so irgendwie
los dass hier kannst du dir mitnehmen
den arm ostend ihr da ja irgendwo okay
ich mache dir einfach so mitnehmen
ich tue das einfach da an eine kiste ich
will jetzt einfach nur einmal testen
wenn ich eigentlich hier
was hab ich ihr manager doch nicht jeder
mitstreiterin diamond league ins das
nicht sondern diamond chain ist
eigentlich auch nicht ja kommt golden
haben wir und was bringt den freitoss
keine ahnung warum finde ich also ich
versuche jetzt mal ob ich in dieser
schmelze auch diese ganzen gold hosen
und so rein tun kann
wer gerne gold hosen in die schmelze
also dass es schmilzt
ja klingt logisch allerdings kann man da
nicht rein tun was machten windsbach das
ist einfach nur ein windstoß na ja das
geht leider nicht schade dachte das geht
jeder macht auch kein damage schade ich
wollte sich nach künftig setzt sich die
luft hinter alter lange wird hier im
flugzeug
das hat das ist im spiel war dass ich
dachte auch als das motorrad bei dir
irgendwie
ich glaube nicht dass laurie 50 asket
köpfe ich bin darüber lägen aber ich
darf er nicht setzen
ich könnte außerhalb von stadt roth war
setzten an den ritter dahin locken
kannst du machen stimmt wie offenbach
kann ich mich selbst eine platte machen
ehre für mich
romano ich will eigentlich den
erweiterten friedhof arbeitet muss man
mal angucken hier er platz vier leichen
platz für beurteilt
soja ist auch in das format was uns
vorgegeben wurden wie sieht diese macht
weil die direkt an der stadtwerke die
stadt muss jedoch allgemein ihm wie weiß
nicht wenn wir bauen jetzt die ganze
stadt in diesem style
ich weiß nicht also weil da muss ich
mein haus gleich nochmal um funktioniert
also ich finde eigentlich jetzt gar
nicht mal so schlecht wie im fall war
ebenso ganz gut hier ja genau ich wollte
halt hier so einen fetten kabel turm in
machen ja dachte mir also nicht nur
kabel turm aber ich habe mir als gedacht
man fängt halt wenn man hausbau hat
fängt man erst mal mit der form an
ich wollte erst mal so einen fetten
kabel turm nach oben hin wie hoch bauen
durch halt einfach und danach mache ich
mir gedanken was für material wir jetzt
egal aussehen ja ok aber sie sagen doch
blicken beide zweimal das außen ist ja
also ich werd ich denke ich werde
wirklich mein haus noch mal abreißen und
das auch so schönen der unserem stil
bauen weil wir brauchen nicht langsamer
sein stil in unserer stadt
das ist wichtig weil wieso ist es so
eine farm in der mitte wo was wie wo was
das finde ich hässlich schon mit meinem
orchester vier fliegen das hier zum
beispiel kukla lasst das mal abreißen
jetzt heißt das jetzt ab alter ja ich
weiß dass jetzt auch auf das kacke paar
veränderungen hier setzten mit könig
ohne witz eine ehre für mich mit dem ok
ich bin natürlich wie lange es noch hier
alles so läuft wie die wahl ausgeht
eigentlich ein könig auch wieder sorge
wiedergewählt werden leider nicht
deswegen ist für mich eigentlich egal ob
die größte scheiße bauen dann mach doch
mal das mal krieg machen gegen england
hätte ich das mache ich jetzt auch ich
hoffe das funktioniert ich wohne jetzt
in dieser folge den ritter außerhalb von
statt
rot-grün kann gefällt mir würde ich
wieder weg muss man auch mal war mal
machen
ja ich komme jetzt hat meine angst
verloren ich komme jetzt geht es mit
spiegeln stadt roth nehme ich hab kein
ich hab mal ein spiegel
ja ich habe spiegel den soli
wahrscheinlicher zwei spiegel sollte ich
wahrscheinlich für ok wat een benutze
ich vielleicht muss man den setzt wie
den spiegel machst was so etwas fällt
hier ab das nervt mich nicht ein
das sind so sachen kennt sich die sachen
in minecraft du immer dran vorbei ist
und die hat man die abbaus und jetzt
setzt ein zeichen und boarder setzt ab
das wirklich so jetzt vor einer ist
angesprochen hat sagen alle ja genauso
sehe ich das auch erholung also ich hab
jetzt beide spiegel hier an der
oberfläche das heißt es war richtig ja
und du wenn du wenn du jetzt willst dass
der eine zb für stadt roth ist dann
musst du ihn statt rot gehen und da den
ein richtiges setzt den umkamen
ich war zauber den jetzt ja dann musst
du den aber da das letzte meiner hand
halten wo du über der erde bist nicht du
ihn jetzt in den looks 80 scheiße hier
ist ja was reichen da stell dich einfach
fordern wenn ich den rucksack tue und
ich auch wieder sowie als wäre ich nicht
draußen dafür die rucksäcke gut als ich
habe jetzt in den verzauberten zu hause
und dann jedoch zu kämpfen jetzt du
kannst ihn jetzt verwenden den spiegel
wenn du irgendwo ein blog über die hast
ja genau
aber jetzt läuft ja noch ein für ihn zu
stroh sozusagen das heißt du musst du
statt rot kommen und ich mussten
electric dafür hab ich kein ob du kannst
auch einfach mein spiegel benutzen und
in stadt roth geht und dann dein spiegel
darauf aktivieren electric sda warum
weil ich fliegen muss vor dem mütter weg
so gut kann ich aber um einen geben
willst musst du mich ausrüsten du bist
gar nicht liebe könig der wird sich das
interesse werde einfach wenn alle krieg
führen dass es der dann noch trotzen
also ja waren unsichtbarkeit machen und
unsichtbarkeit mantel unsichtbar kainz
machenden unsichtbarkeit und wo er
selber und reaper und was mich
aber jetzt ernsthaft da bin ich dann
ziemlich unsicher das mal zeigen alter
wie geil kater cook müsste mich jetzt
sehen sie es mich weiter dynamik welt
siehst du mich dann ja und jetzt immer
noch warte immernoch ja jetzt als ich
dich töten ich bin nur anhalten weil ja
ich sehe du läufst ohne rüstung rum er
weiß geister von sich so als geist ja
gucken wie man warte dann kann ich den
screenshot schicken alter ich sehe das
ganze reihe 5 aber man ist ja nicht mehr
unsichtbar mit der richtigen winter
neuen version nicht mehr komplett man
sich neue geist ja und das fließt auch
noch ändert pro minute ehrlich ja oma
macht lasst das alter das bringt nix und
bis wann hätte
ich dachte schon im krieg ganz einfach
so auf einmal anziehen dann wärst du und
ich bauen können genommen direktor
richter wiesen opfer witzig ja gut das
hier ist jetzt erst mal mehr oder
weniger ausgebaut ausgeglichen braucht
wo habe ich dann meinen seelen steinwand
sehen sind habe ich kann zählen sind
dabei ich frage mich wo man in meinen
weg sport ist hast du meinen export na
ja das hab ich ja gut dass du mal ein
schwert geklaut was eingesammelt beim
ausbau sieht bhp zadar traurigen
einschnitt mehr haltbarkeit als meins
meins auffrischt habe das gar nicht
genommen frisch der ok so schreibt hinzu
frühsorger sein
ja bitte mein blick sword ist bei den
mops haben die das an
doch wieso man jetzt auch mit schnee die
haben wir das rad geklaut was ich in der
hand hatte
die haben wir das gerade geklaut geile
mannschaft das geht nicht hier
doch klar können wir absehen wenn du so
nah dran steht dann ist das natürlich
ein muss und so weit wie möglich weg zu
stehen
diese markierung soll ich nur dran
erinnern
ich brauche nur ich kriege gar nichts
alter richtig kubaners ich will nur
erfahrungen erfahrung als belastung
ausgemacht magazin ich gucken hier
wenn das redstone leuchtet ist die aus
soest erst an wenn die das plakat auf
den geist geht und so sieht ein pieks
mit m in der jane spot auf einmal noch
sky ihr habt angst vor denen da es war
ein wunderschönes giants wort ich
brauche ist aluminium aber ich will ich
will nicht suchen halt da kann man das
irgendwie schmelzen auch schon gekommen
der kasse was man auf geist geht
irgendwas wollte ich machen
achso widersetzen
genau das heißt ich muss jetzt in saint
noch mal kurz aber nicht in treffer
durch die aktion mit angucken was denn
wie ich den ritter in dem stadt locke ja
klar dass mit an
das darf ich das du wirst könig und ihm
das alles nicht setzt sich ein extremes
statt der sonst auch quasi nur ein model
das ist eigentlich nichts ich meine das
ding ist ich mehr oder weniger kam aus
oder verkehrten aber okay wir haben zwar
am anfang gesagt man darf in seine
eigene stadt keinen mob locken aber aus
dem gegnerischen städten gesagt so darf
keine creeper ein loch ich glaube nicht
ich möchte ich da jetzt nicht fest ob
das haben wir gesagt ich will mich da
nicht reden einfach in der nähe alben
spawnen lässt sich noch wundern dadurch
aber wenn ihr uns auch erst mal dran als
haben blauen baum gefunden
ehrlich
girls das heißt das ja da sind die
ehemals ein bisschen trotzdem auch und
blauen baum gefunden
also weil ich habe bloß falls bei mir
soll es gibt guten seelen sind roten ja
den habe ich auch schon gesehen da war
meint expect genau gleich wie der
spitzname zwecks ja er sieht genau aus
wie ein rechner nur halt wählen sand ist
das nächste drohten never reck und wo
seine spitzhacke hatte das gebot mehr
dreck und drohten sehen sein muss das
los alter die richtig hart ab wie
obsidian mohammed ohne schilder die das
urheberrecht aus auf einmal das läuft so
flüssig wie cent heißer sand was machen
erfahren weil sie nicht los fragte ich
nicht alle dach painted soll kann ich
soll center stellen einander ins wort
wird jetzt heftig gemacht hatte an
breaking 3 drauf
auf jeden fall es macht ihr typisches 5
ist schon gar nicht immer klar dass
ingolstadt haben soll soll ich so oder
so stieler drauf machen oder so stil was
ist besser
sollte es auf jeden fall ne das muss wir
haben gelernt was bringt ihr das
ich weiß nicht also mit stil ist es
glaube ich so wenn du in little giants
wort hat dann nimmt das die seelen auf
und repariert sich irgendwie selbst das
hatte ich ja mal eine zeitlang
allerdings dass little giants worten
nicht so gut wie eine energy and sword
und deswegen frage ich mich jetzt dass
ob ein ende das wort auch seelen
einsammelt aber wie seelen und was ist
dieses das die herzen von anderen
schwarz werden wie heißt das dass ist
wird effekt wieso kann ich dann auch
meine energien zwar nicht drauf packen
lassen vergiftung heißt es nicht hängen
green award oder so ich guck mal ganz
kurz bei mir im bett ich weiß es nicht
wenn du es hast sagt wichtiger fuß
glaube ich hab teilung
so ist alles da und grausam
das pack ich mal drauf das hat sich gut
an 28 level braucht dafür dauert doch
nicht so lang eigentlich zu schaffen
können jetzt hab ich mich auch diese
verzauberung dass ich jetzt meine herzen
ganz schwarz ja was konnte mir das
crossgate schieden wie chatten was man
eigentlich schade schade ich kann doch
nicht bieten obwohl ich schon mal
benutzt hatten immer noch kurzem
inventar
ja da wollte ich aber eine rucksacktour
gucken ob das gegner hatte ich doch
wieder in der hand aber jetzt macht
angela weil ich dann direkt wieder
hingehen jetzt vorüber und ich muss
meine musik machen wo ach ja darüber
herrscht im moment ich fahre noch eben
erst gar nicht ein mit damit ich mich
direkt verzögern
hast du noch ich gucke mir das land fern
und kämpfen ja genau ich werde mir auch
dann auch werfen den boden porten und
dann mit der web orten halt ne der
gerade was gesehen weil wir müssen
einmal die volksseele deswegen bin ich
los ok ja wo soll die antworten oder wie
wir das überhaupt daher komme ich raus
ist ein portal
ach so du willst durch das portal ja ich
habe einen spiegel dann geht schon durch
das portal
ich bin jetzt bei denen in der stadt bis
jetzt mal die us-weit georgi am
weihnachtsbaum und ich bin sofort tag
ich bin der vater sie sind also immer
noch ich würde sagen kf warte warte
erstmal platz aussuchen
statt rot
juli
hab kein knopf dafür die auszumachen
solche idioten
er ist es blöd die sich schon von weitem
weg alter ja also wenn man die am
weihnachtsbaum probleme haben ich bin
neben der shader der ist auch ein
bisschen gerster kälte er wieder mit
höhe alle skater sind in die voll hier
ist lang so das sollte schon weit genug
weg von der stadt sein weil das weiter
weg bist du bist du bist du denn hier
auf dem turm wo muss ich von von dehner
wo bist du cap bei 5.570
1 500 5500 und 3800 und 3008 auf den weg
ich bin ja auf berg ist bisher nicht du
bist hier nicht über steam nicht 5572
und 3880 3885 und 5.575 hey hallo also
ich vorne den und bevor er mich erkennt
habe ich dann ab in die richtung ok oh
mein gott gesetzt
jetzt erkennt die leiste grad gar nicht
mehr wettbewerb ist der barbar oder so
das wäre das wäre frech gewesen wir
wissen dass wir das gewesen wären hätten
sich gerechnet
ach so ich wollte sowieso mein ding
machen im moment grad in stadtroda sind
kann ich mir das mal ganz kurz anwalt
ich finde die sind echt schön
organisiert hier außerdem ob verliert ja
keine frage aber wieso brenton diesen
dieser stein bei denen ich weiß nicht
ich weiß nicht warum ich hier so ein
lagerfeuer haben und sowas und ja warum
leuchtet dieser stellen was sind das für
steine schreibt uns dass man die
kommentare das sind auch nicht unsere
steine das ist eben was anderes da ist
doch das ist ein star es doch eigentlich
nein
die dia doch aber die sehen das ist ein
stars dann aber das ist irgendein
anderer wenn ich mal star ein gebe
jedoch nicht das ist nett dass da glaube
ich nenne stars mit will geht man etwas
da ein alter den könnte man noch mal
machen
thomas loos aggregator man brauchen
netweaver bi dass hier ein büro und hier
tue ich jetzt mein in den rucksack genau
hier
so und letztlich zum halleschen
schmecken wie man wirklich ok auf eben
zurück genau dann als das geschenk ist
überbracht nix sagen alles und behaltet
weihnachtsgeschenk veraltetes wissen sie
ich bin wieder zu hause achtung auch
schön euch links kennt mögen ich weiß
noch im konzern
wir beenden wären noch 50 sekunden das
reicht dann kann ich das eben alles
passt alles wunderbar holten so kommt
auch noch dazu
und das kann ich auch weg tun federball
grevenbrock einer hoffe ich nicht
brauche ich nicht brauche ich nicht
brauche ich nicht brauche ich brauche
ich brauche ich bekomme ich trading gar
nicht irgendwie mit gar keinem legen wir
euch das auch nicht fix vorbei war das
da brauch ich nicht ich muss hier
einfach unbedingt setzen bei mir zwar
jetzt noch schnell hier habe ich kein
dach das aber so sagt wenn ich hier
stehe und den rausholen schauen heute
kurz ja ich reduziere raushole bleibt
der stadt rotenburg aber mal kommt aus
mir raushole ja stets am block und der
dürfte nicht dann bist du in statt rot
eigentlich müsste das funktionieren
gleich jetzt mal so orlow nur fünf level
noch zwei level heben wollen eine sind
ja leicht irgendwo noch ein level meine
sind ja schnell so weit vom ersten fünf
gegner übels fertig weil ich ja jetzt
packe ich da nehme ich ihn raus das kann
nicht sein dass das 28 level kostet das
muss etwas heftiges sein
ich will ich damit die schlagen war das
echt heftig ist das schwert aber ich
will mein gott das ist grotesk fff
dieser heftige skelett mein schwert
bitte töte ihn töte
oder hat der mensch wert der mutter
gespielt haben ja gar nicht wussten am
ein schwert das liegt der ort inklusions
leute wir sehen was in der nächsten
folge bleibt doch egal wie schaut's euch
beide sichtbaren du hast ja
wahrscheinlich gesehen wie im sender
wieder weiter bei mir aus st ja hab ich
nicht gesehen weil ich einfach direkt
musste mich nicht an zeit und dann sehen
wir uns bei der nächsten folge bleibt
geile macht's gut bis dahin tschüss